For this button, we have two options.
The content, which says, Eucalyptus.
Or the area that's labeled,
which says, Gumnut.
We just learned that the aria-label
overrides any other native labeling,
including content.
So in this case,
the button will have a label of Gumnut.
For this native checkbox we have
a label field next to it, however,
the label is not correctly
associated with the input.
So the input won't have a label.
We could fix that by giving the checkbox
an ID of roo, as well as a name.
For this div we have a role of
button and content, Wombat.
Normally a div on it's own wouldn't get
included in the accessibility tree.
We would just get the text
node inside of it.
But since it has a role of button,
it will be exposed as a button
with a label, Wombat.
And finally,
this span needs a pretty close look.
It has a role of checkbox.
aria-checked state is false.
aria-labeledby pointing to label.
And aria-label of, Not checked.
So it will be exposed in accessibility
tree because it has a role.
But the label will be one of,
Not checked, and, Wallaby.
We heard in the previous lesson
that aria-labelledby overrides
all other types of labels.
So the label for this will be, Wallaby.